[Musique]
il ya eu des évolutions on voit bien au
niveau législatif au niveau légal que
des mesures ont été prises pour que les
femmes soient plus représentés dans la
vie associative que les femmes soient
plus représentés dans les conseils
d'administration par exemple ou dans les
corps élus pour que l'ailier puisse y
avoir une égalité de salaire notamment
sur dans le secteur dans le secteur
privé mais on voit qu'il reste encore du
chemin
il ya un domaine qui est beaucoup de
plus en plus abordés c'est celui de la
masculinité
c'est à dire qu'il ya un grand travail
qui a été fait pour que les femmes
puissent connaître leurs droits pour
qu'elles aient accès à l'éducation c'est
pas fini il reste encore beaucoup
d'actions à mener en ce sens on se rend
compte que les hommes aussi ont une
perception de leur rôle dans la société
qui contribuent à la domination sur les
femmes
c'est à dire que l'homme doit être fort
l'homme doit aller chercher doit
apporter le plus gros revenus du ménage
l'homme est plutôt à l'extérieur alors
que la femme et à l'intérieur et c'est
donc on voit bien qu'en agissant au
niveau éducatif aussi sur les garçons et
aussi sur les hommes en travaillant sur
la la propre perception de même comme
des êtres à part entière et égalitaire
par rapport aux femmes
où va impacter forcément le sort des
femmes
on avance n'est pas arrivé et ensuite
ces avancées sont aussi inégale en
fonction des territoires
je pense qu'il faut le prendre en compte
moi j'ai toujours et veulent évoluer en
zone urbaine il ya une réflexion à avoir
sur les zones plus rurales des
réflexions à voir aussi
moi je pense à l'échelle internationale
j'ai voyagé dans mon parcours
professionnel j'ai fait des missions à
l'étranger notamment de certains pays où
les femmes n'ont absolument aucun droit
à la parole n'ont pas accès à l'espace
public donc il ya des avancées je pense
que ces avancées
j'espère devrait se diffuser
au plus grand nombre à la fois au
national entre l'urbain et le rural est
à la fois à l'échelle internationale
[Musique]